ونحييكم من جديد يبدو ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا بدات تاخذ منحا مختلفا مع وصول
الطائرات المسيره الى اطراف موسكو في
حادثه غير مسبوقه منذ انطلاع الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الحادثه الاكثر لفتا
للانظار تمثلت في الاعلان عن اسقاط مسيره
في بلده كولومنا على اطراف العاصمه
الروسيه وهذه المره التي تعلن فيها موسكو
وصولها هجمات مماثله الى العاصمه الروسيه
من دون ان يتم الكشف عن تفاصيل اضافيه
السلطات الامنيه اعلنت ان ثلاث مسيرات
اوكرانيه تم اسقاطها في شوارع
بالقرود الروسيه ما الحق بعض الاضرار
بنوافذ المنازل والسيارات كما اعلنت
السلطات الامنيه عن التصدي لجسم طائر سقط
في منطقه اديكيا بالاضافه الى ذلك صرح
حاكم منطقه بريانس كالحدوديه لكسندر
بوجماز بان الجيش تمكن من اسقاط طائره
مسيره اوكرانيه فوق منطقه سروج من تسجيل
وقوع اصابات تكرار مشاهد الطائرات بدون
طيار وضع السلطات الروسيه في حاله تاهب
وفقه صحيفه واشنطن الامريكيه هذا تطور
العسكري يطرح تساؤلات حول الهدف من ذلك
فهل يختبر الغرب رد الفعل الروسي على
اختراق من هذا النوع ام ان الحرب بدات
فعلا تاخذ منحا مختلفا يتجلى بتوسيع
المعركه الى الداخل الروسي
في الاسابيع الاولى من عامها الثاني وجه
جديد للحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اختراق الاجواء الروسيه
والوصول الى اطراف العاصمه هجوم بالمسيرات
يربك موسكو
موجه بتكثيف النشاط الامني والاستخباراتي
في مواجهه التهديدات الجديده
واكد ان بلاده سترد بالوسائل اللازمه على
كل تهديد للامن القومي
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من موسكو
يفجني سدرا المحلله السياسي اهلا بك من
كيافه دكتور الكسندر بجمالوف مدير المعهد
الوطني الاوكراني للدراسات الاستراتيجيه
اهلا بكم مع ضيفاي واسم حالي ان ابدا من
موسكو معك
نتحدث على استهداف او على الاقل صواريخ
يقال بالخطا نزلت او سقطت على الحدود
الروسيه من الجانب الاوكراني بدنا نتحدث
عن استهداف محيط موسكو ما الذي يمثل ذلك
نعم تحيه لك ولساده المشاهدين والديكم
الكريم اولا
للتدقيق يعني هذه المدينه التي
سقطت في محيطها
مسيره ربما اوكرانيه تبعد عن موسكو حوالي
100 كيلومتر وبالتالي هي ليس من اطراف
موسكو هي قريبا قريبه طبعا من موسكو
ولكنها لا يعتبر من دواحي او من ريف موسكو
مثلا مع ذلك طبعا هذا الامر يبعث على
القلق لدى العسكريين الذين يشعرون الى
ضروره ابداء المزيد من اليقظه وتجديد ربما
وتقويه الدفاعات الجويه التي تحمي سما
موسكو وغيرها من كبريات المدن الروسيه
وبشكل امن مع ذلك طبعا هناك ثغرات يمكن ان
تستغلها المسيرات المعاديه بالنسبه لروسيا
طبعا وهي
تحلق على ارتفاعات منخفضه وهذا براي
الخبراء العسكريين ربما يمكن ان يشكل
الخطر ولكن احتمال ان تخترق مسيره صحيحه
ولكن حضرتك تتحدث وكانك تتحدث عن امر واقع
تتحدث عن
مسيرات قادره ان تستهدف المدن اتحدث في
المقابل عن ان خطوط الدفاع الروسيه
متحضره لذلك وكاننا بيتنا امام مرحله
جديده وهي مرحله قد تنتقل الى الداخل
الروسي
انا لي اعتقد لا اعتقد بان هناك مبالغه او
هناك تناقض في كلامي لانه طبعا من جهه كما
قلت دفاعات جويه قويه جدا بالنسبه لحمايه
المدن ولكنها بحاجه الى ربما تعزيز من قبل
مثلا صواريخ من طراز تور
وهي قويه جدا واستخدمت في العديد من
النقاط الساخنه بما في ذلك في قاعده حميمي
الروسيه وهي امنه جدا لكن مع ذلك كما قلت
هناك ثغرات ناتجه عن كون البصيرات تحلق
الارتفاعات منخفضه وهذا ما يتيح لها ربما
بالتوسط الى عمق الاراضي الروسيه سيد
الكسندر هذا الاستهداف الاخير والذي وصف
بغير المسبوق حسب قراءه حضرتك هل هو جس
نبض لروسيا هل هو محاوله لمعرفه مدى
صبرها مدى قدرتها كيف تفسر ذلك
يعني هناك بعض المشاكل منهجيه يعني في
الترحقكم لهذه الخبر يعني مشاكل او مشاكل
او مشاكل
معلومه وارده من موسكو ايه معلومه وارده
من موسكو يعني بدون تاكيد من الجانب
الاوكراني لاي سوى شيء
موسكو تقوم باستمرار بالحرب نفسيه وببصمه
معلومات كاذبه عن كل شيء ليحصل يعني سواء
كان في اراضيه او خارج اراضيه من المؤكد
ان هناك في موسكو العديد من الاحداث يعني
هناك خرائط مستمره يعني هناك خرائط
مجمعات تجاريه يعني في مناخي في ليس فقط
في موسكو حتى في المناطق بعيده من الحدود
الاوكرانيه بعيده جدا يعني في الشرق
البلاد في القسم الاسيوي على سبيل المثال
يعني هناك العديد من المشاكل تحصل حاليا
وحاله
حاله الزعر يعني
تسود يعني هذا البلد لانه بعد ما ورط ورط
القروسي البلد يعني في هذه الحرب يعني
خليني افهم فقط من حضرتك حضرتك تقول بانه
ليست هناك استهدافات لداخل الروسي
وبتحمل تحملنا خليني سؤال حضرتك تحملنا
السؤال
تحملنا مسؤوليه نقل الاخبار او ردتها ولكن
ليست روسيا فقط هناك جهات اعلاميه اخرى
غربيه كذلك تحدثت
هذا الخبر يعني فنحن الخبر الطرف الثاني
في هذه الحرب ليس غرب انما اوكرانيا نحن
نقود
طيب خلينا نتاكد من سيدني لي ست هناك
سيده هناك ام لا مسيارات استهدفت مناطق في
محيط حضرتك تقول بعيده بمئه كيلومتر على
موسكو ولكن هل هذا الخبر على الاقل اكيد
ام لا
هذا الخبر شبه مؤكد يمكن القول لانه ليس
من ليس حتى الان ليس هناك وضوح تامه حول
يعني تبعيت هذه المسيره ان امكن القول
ولكن الفرضيه مثلا اجراء عمليه تخريب
بداخل الروسي بواسطه
بعملاء
الاستخبارات او اجهزه الاستخبارات
المعاديه تبدو انها ضئيله جدا وهذا ما
يؤكد ربما اراء الكثير من المحللين
والخبراء العسكريين بانها من اوكرانيا
طبعا
المصادر الاوكرانيه في كما قال ضيفكم هذا
الخبر نافيا قاطعا ولكن هناك معطيات
موضوعيه ولا يؤكدها فقط الجانب الروسي
وانما كما تفضلت انت
العديد من مصادر اخرى بما فيها غربيه
وبالتالي ربما عدم وضوح تام حول هذا
الموضوع ولكن من الملفت للنظر ان هذا هو
ثاني حادث للتوغل الذي قامت به مسيره ربما
اوكرانيه وقريبا بشكل نسبي من موسكو لانه
منذ ثلاثه اسابيع نفس الحادثه وقعت في
منطقه كالوها وهي تبعد عن موسكو حوالي مئه
كيلومتر ايضا مثل منطقه كولومنا وبالتالي
يمكن القول ان هناك ربما
سلسله من من هذه الاعمال التي يجري تخطيط
لها مسبقا وربما بواسطه
المصادر التي
بواسطه المعلومات التي تقدمها للجانب
الاوكراني ان تاكدت هذه الفرضيه
الاستخبارات
الغربيه بما فيها طبعا الامريكيه بدرجه
الاولى صحيح سيد الكسندر ان سلمنا جدلا
بما تفضلت به منذ قليل
بانه ليس هناك وجود لهذه الاستهدافات وليس
هناك وجود لمسيرات استهدفت محيط موسكو طيب
نسلم جدلا بما قلته سيطرح سؤال ما مصلحه
موسكو في الاعلان وهكذا اعلان قد يهز
صورتها
شوف يعني خلال هذه السنه يعني
روسيا يعني واجهت مشاكل يعني مع اداره
الشرب في اوكرانيا هناك انتكاسات بعد
الانتكاسات هناك عدم وجوده تقدم ملموس
يعني على ساحه القطار خلال فتره طويله جدا
ففقدت روسيا اراضي الاتيه احتلتها سابقا
يعني هناك اشياء كبيره من الاراضي المحتله
من قبل الروس تحررت
وكذلك قدره قتاليه الروسيه من
منتزع مفقوده يعني بشكل كبير جدا يعني
مما يسبب يعني في حاله الياس يعني في لدى
الجمهور الروسي وبالذات المتطرفين
القوميين الذين هم اكبر مشاجعا لهذه الحرب
الذي يعتمد يعني نظام على رايهم يعني وعلى
تشجيعهم يعني في هذا الحرب
لجات روسيا الى الى الى تكتيك يعني تكتيك
معلومات يعني في دار الحرب المعلوماتيه
يعني
المقصود يعني بها
اقناع الجمهور الروسي ان هي روسيا التي هي
ليست ليست صبرت العذران انما هي الضحيه او
ضحيه محتمله يعني في هذا الحرب فالحرب هذه
الدفاعيه يعني توصيف هذه الحرب او تصوير
هذه الحرب كانها دفاع عن الوطن عن الروس
يعني هو المقصود يعني بكل هذا الكلام
بمعنى انه هناك استهداف لدخلنا فعلينا ان
نرد ما رايك سيدي افجيني ما رايك في طرح
ضيفي بالقول بانه هذه اخبار غير صحيحه
وروسيا تستفيد منها وهذه الرسائل داخل
الروسي
لا هي ليست برسائل الى داخل الروسي لان
هناك لا يوجد اي مداعات للخوف رغم ان من
يتحكم من يقف وراء هذه العمليه عمليه
المسيرات طبعا ربما يرمي الى مثل هذا
الهدف هو زرع الخوف ربما وحتى زعر ولكن
ليس هناك من مثل هذا المزاج لدى الاكثريه
الساحقه من المواطنين الروس فهم لا يخشون
من هكذا حوادث الان والان سابقا ولربما في
المستقبل تفضل
لتخويف داخل الروسي بالعكس هو للقول بانه
لدينا اسباب لدينا اسباب للدفاع فنحن
ندافع عن سيادتنا عن دخلنا
هذا الملف ليس له علاقه
بالاهداف المعلنه من قبل القياده الروسيه
حول هذه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه التي
تستمر لاكثر من سنه لانه هذه الاهداف لا
يجمعها اي جامعه مع ما حدث
بالمسيرات لانها وقايه تؤكدها العديد من
المصادر وليس هناك
صحيح هناك حتى جهات اعلاميه غربيه اوردت
هذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا لكم على المشاركه
وكل ما تفضلتم به من موسكو المحلل السياسي
ومن قياده الدكتور الكسندر بوكو لوف مدير
المعهد الوطني الاوكراني للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه شكرا لكما
السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]